[BLANK_AUDIO]
The heart and soul of this course are its projects. I can't really teach you to
design. You have to learn it by doing it yourself. The best I can do is to
introduce you to some specific techniques, such as modeling, and technology,
such as UML, that you can use in thinking about how to solve design problems.
The learning experience comes from applying them to a problem and getting a feel
for how they work. A course on software design faces an important challenge.
Interesting design typically occurs when confronting large complex problems but
those can't be dealt with within the constraints of a single course.
I have taken a different approach to structuring projects called design studies.
The idea here comes from a world of building architecture in which
the architect often constructs a variety of small scale models in order to
explore a design space. For each of the projects in this course,
I ask you to solve it several different ways and then to systematically study
the differences. The projects themselves are relatively small, and
although some coding is involved, you will be working on teams with
enough members that you should have enough resources to get the job done, and
then study the variations. I've also tried to make the projects similar to
those in the real world. The first similarity is that you will be
working with team members that you are not colocated with. You will have to
learn to quickly organize yourself to work in a parallel distributive fashion.
The second similarity, is that the projects are some what open ended. That is,
though they are basically requirements, there is room for
you to be creative in your solutions, and to go beyond those requirements,
if you believe you can significantly add value to the product you are producing.
Of course, the danger with an open ended project is you might get engaged in
polishing an extension and not have a working solution to the basic problem.
I strongly suggest that you tackle these projects in an incremental manner,
that is, begin by producing a trivial working program providing only
minimal functionality then add one new feature at a time.
Ensuring that the older functionality still works.
The third similarity to the real world is that the projects are phased. What
this means is that the three projects all deal with the same problem domain and
each subsequent project builds on the solutions developed in the previous ones.
In fact, you're specifically encouraged to make use of code. From your own or
other teams that was developed earlier. This situation is typical of
the real world, where successful projects often have long lifetimes in
which the additional features are added and released to customers.
The fourth similarity is that the members of your project team change for
each phase. In the real world, turnover of teams is common and
you have to learn to work with a variety of people. One specific benefit is that
by having team members with different teams, you will have familiarity with and
access to a variety of working solutions from which you can choose components
from previous phases. More over, managing teams in this fashion provides
a motivation for designing your solutions in a way that they can be reused on
future projects. Even if you don't know exactly what those projects are.